au bas mot
au vu de la mer et le cherche midi
ouais
bon
c'est cette seule ville il s'entend bien
c'est normal connaît sa carrière au
combat
non ça m'impose du joug alors dit moi
avec tous ses records la t100 art est
absent tout ça on se sait pas si tu sais
ce qui se passe en france on peut a dit
que j'ai pas besoin de savoir
en fait j'avais mise à jour est ce que
tu sais qu'il est l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de foot
domenech bien est ce que tu sais la
sphère clearstream c'est quoi aucune
idée malgré ça lui a aucune idée
non mais ça il sait pas mais c'est
normal il est sans arrêt tu peux vjesnik
titouan clearstream
voilà c'est une affaire très compliquée
c'est une à l'origine c'est une banque
qui lessiveuse quoi ils sont vos
luxembourg qui transforme de l'argent
bizarre en argent correct alors les gens
qui ont un compte là bas en fait sont
des numéros c'est ça envoie ses ombres
elle en france à un peu merdé parce
qu'on a mis sur la tête de certains
hommes des comptes qui n'existait pas il
ya certes un autre homme qu'on voulu
faire plonger ces hommes là en faisant
croire qu'ils en avaient césar c'est
exactement ça donne envie de revenir
ouais olivier a on va voir si tu au camp
qui a été blanchi de ces condamnations
par jacques chirac
10 10 rue gracié par le président la
république qui couche avec lara fabian
facile ça devrait toujours selon as le
nom de la victime
gérard pullicino ça fabuleux réalisateur
de télévision uer immaculé bons progrès
donc la victime effectivement qui est
harry roselmack
c'est le présentateur noir de tf1 darry
cowl moreau pas mort mort
louis saez philippe castelli voir
jacques martin
vivent très bien bah oui qui a dit la
france aimez là ou quittez la sarkozy
non mais attends non mais c'est pas
foutu milliers c'est pour voir si si
quand on est à l'étranger mais pas l'eau
avec quoi sarkozy veut-il nettoyer la
racaille au karcher bien qui est
champion de france de foot au las olas
non mais non mais c'est normal c'est
messi sur tf1 qu' à ce jour là on est
quelle année vu ou et lionel jospin
chez lui c'est bien
keddy la route est droite mais la pente
est raide rapin en attendant
l'adversaire à pagaie tulle en merci ce
déficit quand je suis parti ils étaient
là on était là-bas oui tout autant moi
j'étais au japon s'était emparé estivale
en australie pour ça on fait ça pour te
mettre à jouer mais c'est pas la peine
ça m'intéresse pas du tout je ne
m'intéresse pas de savoir pourquoi
florent pagny va en argentine quel est
le métier est ce que charles trenet est
mort bah ouais il était mort avant le
départ alors qu'il est toujours très gai
est ce que tu sais qu alain delon a
promis qu'il ne referait pas de cinéma
non je peux pas savoir qu'alain des
pâturages il devrait s'en féliciter est
ce que tu sais à qui la femme de delon a
refait sa vie
ah oui assez intéressante et c'est inouï
non mais s'il ya un mec qui s'adresse
aux histoires de cul c'est moi dans le
cul ouais je sais pas afflelou ouais non
laisser derrière soi n'a qu'à voir
tourner sa cavale a bien plutôt hong
kong pacific est à dire qu'elle est en
bonne là bas c'est le pays des
kangourous
1 que s'est il passé le 12 septembre
2001 j'ai le lendemain du 11
est ce que tu sais pourquoi tout le
monde embarque s'arrête juste que tu
viens de me poser comme question c'est
pas le cas
cash devant la banque m
c'est le cherche midi mais la personne